another member has joined Mercedes
compact car family says our car tester
enos pet li the most recent addition is
the CLA Shooting Brake there's not much
difference between the CLA
shooting-brake in the four-door coupe a
version until you get to the back of the
car the roofline flows like the coupe a
to the rear Mercedes describes the CLA
shooting-brake as a lifestyle station
wagon and we're going to find out what
that means as far as design goes
mercedes laid an important foundation in
2012 with the new a-class that was a
shift from a conservative image to a
younger target group the plan worked
Mercedes has managed to attract new and
younger customers and with the CLA
Shooting Brake mercedes has brought the
idea of the lifestyle station wagon
familiar from the bigger CLS Shooting
Brake
to the compact class
the CLA Shooting Brake is the fifth
member of our compact car family says
y'all connect from Mercedes it extends
the line using the basic idea of the CLS
Shooting Brake so it's a design oriented
sporty car with a large practical hatch
and a perfect addition to the range
there are two diesel and four gasoline
engines to choose from we're testing the
all-wheel drive CLA 250 Shooting Brake
with 155 kilowatts and dual clutch
transmission packing 350 Newton meters
of torque the car accelerates from 0 to
100 kilometers an hour in 6.8 seconds
with a top speed of 240 kilometers an
hour
driven gently Mercedes puts consumption
at 6.6 liters over 100 kilometers
this button switches between different
modes says heinous so you can have a
really sporty ride
the front of the shooting-brake boasts
all the hallmarks of the compact class
the limited orange art edition adds
extra design details like orange angel
eyes and the bi-xenon headlights add
dashes of color on the front grille
surround and on the alloy wheels in
profile the flat window design is
striking the low greenhouse is how the
salespeople describe it the flowing form
isn't just striking and modern it's also
pretty unbeatable when it comes to air
resistance with a drag coefficient of
0.26 the CLA has set a new standard for
a car of its class
but just how practical is the design
really and what does the sleek design
cost in terms of space and visibility
Medina says the design does affect the
drivers all-round vision a little a
glance in the rearview mirror shows how
small the hatch window is and if you get
a little too close to the traffic lights
the roof can obstruct the view the
interior is also sporty and striking
metallic trimmings on the steering wheel
and the round air vents suggest power
and strength and the view splash out the
extra 6,500 euros for the orange art
edition you can expect colorful accents
inside too like the orange contrasting
top stitching on the performance seats
which are upholstered with leather and
microfiber the contrast on the seatbelts
is an eye-catcher - inna says there's
little difference between the height of
a CLA Shooting Brake compared to the
4-door coupe a you have to watch your
head a little but once you're in there's
enough head and legroom and the trunk
offers a reasonable amount of luggage
space there's up to 1354 litres with the
rear seats folded down
and Germany the CLA Shooting Brake has a
starting price of around 30,000 euros
collision prevention and attention
assists come as standard Mercedes
Shooting Brake is aimed at fans of
competing OD & VW models our tester says
opinions may differ on whether or not
the CLA shooting-brake is a classical
station wagon or not but one thing's
clear this new Mercedes certainly stands
out so if a sedans a little too
conservative for you and a station
wagons too boxy the CLA Shooting Brake
provides an interesting alternative